[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good afternoon, everybody.
My name is Dan Carpenter.
I teach in the government
department here at Harvard.
And I direct the social sciences
program in academic ventures
at the Radcliffe Institute.
I want to begin by acknowledging
the Wampanoag, Massachusetts,
and Nipmuc peoples on whose
homelands we gather today.
And before turning to the Layli
Long Soldier poetry event,
I want to give you,
first, a welcome on behalf
of the Radcliffe Institute
and on behalf of our dean,
Lizabeth Cohen, who
cannot be with us today,
and also just to offer a remark.
What is happening today,
this poetry series,
this event with Layli
Long Soldier and others
are part of a larger
collaboration,
between the Radcliffe Institute
and the Harvard University
Native American
program, to enhance
the visibility, the presence the
continuance of native peoples
at Harvard University,
in collaboration
with the native
communities in our midst
and in keeping with
what we hope is
a much better embrace of
Harvard's responsibilities,
under its charter, to engage
with, collaborate with,
and continue the presence
of native communities.
That includes past events
in this poetry reading,
including an appearance by the
Anishinaabe poet Gerald Vizenor
and the Navajo poet Luci
Tapahonso in recent years,
by the 2016 conference "Native
Peoples, Native Politics,"
by Monday's event, "Citizen
Indigenous,"-- which I hear
was a grand success.
I'm sorry I wasn't
able to make it--
and by an ongoing
research project.
And I'm listing just a few of
many ongoing collaborations,
again, between
Radcliffe and HUNAP,
called the Digital Archive
of Native American Petitions
in Massachusetts, which
is in the process,
in the coming weeks,
of publishing over
500 Native American
petitions currently
in the Massachusetts
archives online,
from the 1640s to the 1870s.
This is a collaboration that has
been enriching and educational
for Radcliffe.
I hope it's been
somewhat that for HUNAP.
We're proud to be
collaborating with HUNAP.
And we intend to do
so for years to come.
I want to now turn over the
event to Dr. Nick Estes.
Nick Estes is a member of
the Lower Brule Sioux tribe.
He's Kul Wicasa from the
Lower Brule Sioux tribe.
And in 2014, he founded
the group the Red Nation
in Albuquerque, New Mexico.
The Red Nation is a native-led
political organization
committed to revitalizing
indigenous kinship relations
and combating anti-indigenous
violence in all
of its manifestations, whether
from police or prisons,
discrimination in off
reservation spaces,
against native women,
youth, and LGBTQ2 issues.
He is currently a
doctoral candidate
in American studies at the
University of New Mexico.
But actually, to update
that-- apologies-- he
is the American Democracy
fellow at the Charles Warren
Center for North
American history,
here, at Harvard, and
assistant professor
in American studies at the
University of New Mexico.
And I'm sorry I butchered
something there for certain.
But you can get me
back another time.
So it is with honor and pride
that we welcome Layli Long
Soldier today.
But first, Dr. Nick Estes.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
I want to again recognize
the original homelands
of the Massachusett peoples as
well as the shared territory
of the Wampanoag and Nipmuc.
I also want to extend
a thank you to HUNAP
for supporting this and
keeping these kinds of events
going at Harvard University.
Having been here for
just under a year,
I have a profound appreciation
for the kind of work
that people like Shelly
and Jason do here.
And I also want to thank
the Radcliffe Institution.
And I'm saying these thank yous,
because I've never introduced
a fellow Lakota writer before.
So it's a big deal for me.
And it couldn't have
been more of a privilege
to introduce one
of our own such,
as Layli Long Soldier, who is a
citizen of the Ogallala Lakota
Nation.
And from what I understand,
this year's theme,
for the Radcliffe Institute,
is citizenship and belonging.
And Layli holds a BFA,
from the Institute
of American Indian Arts, and
an MFA from Bard College.
She has served as a contributing
editor of Drunken Boat.
Her poems have appeared in the
American Poet, the American
Reader, the Kenyon Review
Online, and other publications.
And she is the author of
the chapbook, Chromosomory,
and Whereas, which won the
National Books Critics Circle
Award and was a finalist for
the National Book Awards.
And in 2015, Layli was awarded
the National Artist Fellowship
from the Native Artists
and Cultures Foundation
and a Lannan Literary
Fellowship for her poetry.
And without further
ado, please give a warm
welcome to Layli Long Soldier.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you so much, Nick.
Layli [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
First of all, before
I start, I want
to say I forgot to
bring my other glasses.
So I can't see the best.
So I'm going to do my best here.
I'm going to start off with
some poems about grass,
because the sky is gray outside.
And we've had some snow.
And it makes me want something
a little warmer right now.
So we'll start there.
Oh, goodness.
[LAUGHS]
"Look."
"The light grass
body whole wholly
moves a green hill 'til
I pull stalk 'n root up
from black matte soil bed.
Beads from grass heads,
one by one a part
I split grass wires, little
bulbs, silver green drop
lets I sentence to life
less light quick dead grass
skulls, weight less pile,
dry mound in cupped palm.
What have I done?
What now to do?
Why this impulse to
shake the dead light?
Why do I so want the light
to blink, look alive, move?
Why do I so want it still?"
I wrote that.
I wrote a lot about
grass in this book.
And a lot of that was
because, at the time when
I wrote most of these poems, I
was living in the Four Corners,
on the Navajo Nation.
And when I would go up
north to visit my family,
always, the first thing
that represented home
was the grass, the smell
and the sight of it.
And then, when I would come
back to the Four Corners,
Southwest, that was the
first thing I would miss
is the grass.
But I noticed that--
And this little poem was kind
of like about the dark side
of myself.
As much as I love the
grass, the first thing
I noticed I would do,
when I would go up north,
is grab a handful and
then pick it apart.
And one day I said,
what is my problem?
Why so destructive?
[LAUGHS]
"Steady Summer."
"Solstice grasses, see this
one's a natural anesthetic,
he said.
When they fast,
they cannot food.
Careful water so slide,
grass needle tips
around the edges of
wounds this summer.
Potent grass songs,
a grass chorus moves.
Shhh.
Through half-propped
windows, I swallow
grass scent, the solstice.
Makes a mind wide.
Makes it oceanic blue,
a field in crests,
swirling gyres, the moving
surface fastened in June light.
Here I'm certain that certain
kinds of talk only equal pain.
Excusing myself, I
paddle grass waves.
I'm safer outdoors than in.
In those heady grasses, the
mouth loosens, confesses.
I don't trust nobody
but the land, I said.
I don't mean present
company, of course.
You understand, the grasses
hear me, too, always.
Present the grasses.
Confident grasses,
polite--" excuse me.
Excuse me.
"--polite command to shhh.
Shhh, listen.
At the bottom of trailer
steps, grasshoppers power up,
plate bodies, jet wings
knock knock high speed
thru a swaying green page,
single-spaced, blades bold
hollow stems, air italics.
Shhh.
In midday open, two
horseflies love-buzz,
a simple humid
meeting, motorized sex
in place, then loose again,
infinite circle eights.
Shhh.
Listen.
Down the path, Auntie
steps onto the porch.
The dog pads across wood planks,
a pause to nudge her foot.
Shhh.
In my thoughts, I hear
her, two states away,
ask for more mac 'n cheese.
This is good, Dad, my favorite.
Their forks click in blue
gardens, flowered borders,
scrubbed second-hand plates.
Shhh.
This grass shhh.
[MUSICAL CELLPHONE RING]
Shhh."
What an interesting exchange.
[LAUGHTER]
Good timing.
"Who have I become?"
I have something to say
quickly about that piece.
I'm having a little
conversation, right now.
Well, I'm a little behind.
But we started this
conversation between myself
and Solmaz Sharif.
Are you familiar with her work?
And she has a piece where
she uses the word "whereas"
repetitively, as well.
So we're kind of discussing
our work with that language.
But she was talking a
little bit about the use
of the erotic in her work and
how important that was in order
to kind of humanize her position
in the world and her people,
that humanization.
And so, anyway, I
really appreciated that.
And I was thinking--
but I couldn't help but think,
oh, have I done that in my work
at all?
Is there that presence?
And I couldn't think
of any instance.
And the closest I got was
two horseflies [LAUGHS]
in this piece.
[LAUGHS] Too embarrassed
I think that I'm going to
actually move on and read
from the second part
of my book, which
is the self-titled
section, "Whereas."
And that is where I respond
to the national apology
to Native Americans.
So I think I'll start
off with the introduction
to that section.
Just in case you don't know
much about that apology,
it's a little background.
On Saturday,
December 19th, 2009,
US President Barack Obama signed
the Congressional Resolution
of Apology to Native Americans.
No tribal leaders or
official representatives
were invited to witness or
receive the apology on behalf
of their tribal nations.
President Obama never read
the apology aloud, publicly,
although, for the record,
Senator Brownback,
five months later, read the
apology to a gathering of five
tribal leaders.
Bearing in mind, there are
over 560 federally recognized
tribes.
So 5 out of 560, I
think, is less than 1%.
The apology was then folded
into a larger, unrelated piece
of legislation, called the 2010
Defense Appropriations Act.
[LAUGHTER]
So [LAUGHS] yeah,
that was me, too.
Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
I mean I understand that that's
how things get moved through.
But it says a lot.
So my response is
directed to the apology--
excuse me, the apology's
delivery, as well as
the language, crafting, and the
arrangement of their written
document.
"I am a citizen of
the United States.
And I am enrolled.
I'm an enrolled member of
the Ogallala Lakota tribe,
meaning I am a citizen of
the Ogallala Lakota Nation.
And in this dual citizenship,
I must work, I must eat,
I must mother, I must
friend, I must listen.
I skipped one.
I must art.
I must observe.
Constantly, I must live."
"Whereas when offered an
apology, I watch each movement,
the shoulders high or
folding, tilt of the head,
both eyes down or through me.
I listen for cracks in
knuckles or in the word choice.
What is it that I want?
To feel.
And mind you, I feel
from the senses.
I read each muscle.
I ask the strength of the
gesture to move like a poem.
Expectation's a terse
arm-fold, a failing
noun-thing I scold myself
in the mirror for holding.
Because I learn
from young poets.
One sends me new work,
spotted with salt crystals
she metaphors as her tears.
I feel her phrases, quote,
"I say," and "Understand me,"
and "I wonder."
Pages are cavernous
places, white at entrance,
black in absorption.
Echo.
If I'm transformed by language,
I am often crouched in footnote
or blazing in title.
Where in the body do I begin?"
"Whereas a friend senses
what she calls cultural
emptiness in a poet's work.
And after reading, she feels bad
for feeling bad for the poet,
she admits.
I want to respond,
the same could
be said for me, some sticky
current of Indian emptiness.
I feel it not just
in my poems, but when
I'm on drives, in conversations,
or as I lie down to sleep.
But since this dialogue
is about writing,
I want to be correct
with my languageness.
In a note following
the entry for "Indian"
an Oxford dictionary
warns: do not
use "Indian" or
"Red Indian" to talk
about American native peoples,
as these terms are now
outdated; use "American
Indian" instead."
[CHUCKLES] I'm so
grateful to know that.
Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
"So I explain,
perhaps the same could
be said for my work, some burden
of American Indian emptiness
in my poems, how American
Indian emptiness surfaces
not just on the page but often
on drives, in conversations,
or when I lie down to sleep.
But the term "American Indian"
points--" excuse me-- "parts
our conversation, like
a hollow, bloated boat
that is not ours, that
neither my friend nor I
want to board
knowing it will never
take us anywhere but to rot.
If the language of race is ever
really attached to emptiness.
Whatever it is, I feel now has
me in the hull, head, knees,
feet curled, I dare
say, to fetal position,
but better stated
as the form I resort
to inside the jaws
of a reference."
That piece I read was
actually the first piece
I wrote for this whole series.
I remember being
frustrated, at home,
when this apology came out.
I had a lot to say about it.
I had never really
written work that
was overtly political
or directly political.
But one day I decided--
I thought-- I felt
so frustrated.
I was like, well, there's
a lot that I cannot do.
But one thing I can do is write.
I can do that.
So I'm going to do it.
So I remember sitting down,
and that was the first piece.
And I got out the dictionary--
that was the first thing I
did--
to look up "Indian" to see how
it is defined, in the Oxford
dictionary, of all
things, and to see
what is used to refer to
me, in that case, you know?
But anyway, I remember
it getting done
and feeling really--
it felt good.
It felt good to get
to write something.
But as soon as I
was done, I realized
that one piece was not enough.
It would not be enough.
So I ended up writing 28 pieces.
[LAUGHS]
So I'm going to read a piece.
Now that I read about how
we're referred to in English,
this is a piece how we
understand ourselves,
at least Lakota people, which
is a very different feeling
to say, I'm American Indian.
Actually, I never say that.
But to say that is a very
different feeling than to say,
I am Lakota.
And that's something
we've called ourselves
for much longer.
"Whereas I did not desire in
childhood to be a part of this
but desired most of
all to be a part,
a piece combined with others
to make up a whole, some
but not all of something.
In Lakota it's onspa, a
piece or part of anything,
like the creek trickling behind
my auntie's house, where Uncle
built her a bridge to cross
from bank to bank, not
far from a grassy clearing, with
three tipis, a place to gather.
She holds three-day workshops
on traditional arts.
Young people from
Kyle and Potato Creek
arrive, one by one,
eager to part-ticipate.
They have the option,
my auntie says,
to sleep at home or
return in the morning.
But by and large, they'll
stay and camp even
during South Dakota winters.
The comfort of being together.
I think of Plains
winds, snow drifts, ice,
and limbs, the exposure.
And when I slide my
arms into a wool coat
and put my hand
to the door knob,
ready to brave
the sub-zero dark,
someone says, be
careful out there.
Always consider the
snow your friend.
Think badly of it,
snow will burn you.
I walk out remembering
that for millennia, we
have called ourselves Lakota,
meaning "friend or ally."
This relationship to the
other, some but not all,
still our piece to everything."
When I was working
on this response,
I started researching apologies
around the world, even
other US apologies.
There was a whole apology
to native Hawaiian people,
for example.
There was an apology, in
Canada, to First Nations
people for the residential
schools and so on.
So that was something I
was thinking about a lot,
meditating on.
And then I also thought a lot
about apologies in my own life.
And I wrote this piece.
This is, actually,
I would consider
the heart of this book.
It was probably the
most effective apology
I've ever had.
And this is about my dad.
"Whereas I heard a noise
I thought was a sneeze.
At the breakfast table,
pushing eggs around my plate,
I wondered if he liked
my cooking, thought
about what to talk about.
He pinched his fingers to
the bridge of his nose,
squeezed his eyes.
He wiped.
I often say he was a terrible
drinker when I was a child.
I'm not afraid to say it,
because he's different now,
sober, attentive,
showered, eating.
But in my childhood, when
things were different,
I rolled onto my side, my
hands together, as if to pray,
locked between my knees.
When things were
different, I lay there
for long hours, my face
to the wall, blink.
My eyes left me, my soldiers,
my two scouts to the unseen.
And because language
is the immaterial,
I never could speak
about the missing,
so perhaps I cried for
the invisible, what
I could not see, doubly.
What is it to wish for
the absence of nothing?
There, at the breakfast
table, as an adult
wondering what to talk about,
if he liked my cooking, pushing
the invisible to
the plate's edge,
I looked up to see
he hadn't sneezed.
He was crying.
I'd never heard him cry,
didn't recognize the symptoms.
I turned to him when
I heard him say,
I'm sorry I wasn't there,
sorry for many things.
Like that curative
voicing, an opened bundle
or medicine or birthday wishing,
my hand to his shoulder.
It's OK, I said.
It's over now.
I meant it.
Because of our faces blankly,
because of a lifelong stare
down, because of
centuries in sorry."
You guys want to
hear my mad poem?
When I get mad, it's really
hard for me to say anything,
sometimes, right in the moment.
I don't know.
I'm so slow, too.
You know, like I can't think
on my feet all the time.
I have to go home and
like stew in it, you know?
And then I come up
with the perfect--
so then I just write about it.
So that's my way of getting mad.
I'm really mad.
[TYPING SOUNDS] [LAUGHS]
I'll write a poem.
Shall I read my mad poem?
[LAUGHS] It's best
you get, sorry.
"Whereas a string-bean
blue-eyed man leans back
into a swig of beer, work-weary
lips at the dark bottle,
keeping cool in short
sleeves and khakis,
he enters the discussion.
Whereas his wrist loose
at the bottleneck,
he comes across as candid.
Well, at least there was an
Apology, that's all I can say,
he offers to the circle,
each of them scholarly.
Whereas under
starlight, the fireflies
wink across East Coast grass."
Yes, I was on the East Coast.
[LAUGHS]
"I sit there, painful in my
silence, glued to the bench,
in the midst of the
American casual.
Whereas a subtle electricity
in that low purple light,
I felt their eyes on my
face gauging a reaction.
And someone's discomfort leaks
out in a well-stated, hmm.
Whereas like a bird darting
from an oncoming semi,
my mind races to the
Apology's assertion."
Quote-- so this is from
the National apology.
"While the establishment of
permanent European settlements
in North America
did stir conflict
with nearby Indian
tribes, peaceful
and mutually beneficial
interactions also took place.
Whereas I cross my arms
and raise a curled hand
to my mouth, as if thinking.
As if taking it in, I
allow a static quiet,
then choose to stand up.
Excusing myself, I
leave them to unease.
Whereas I drive down the road
replaying the get-together,
how a man and his beer
bottle stated their piece.
And I reel at what I could
have said or done better.
Whereas I could've
but didn't broach
the subject of "genocide,"
the absence of this term
from the Apology
and it's rephrasing
as "conflict" for example.
Whereas since the moment had
passed, I accept what's done.
And the knife of my
conscience slices
with bone-clean self-honesty.
Whereas in a stirred conflict
between settlers and an Indian
that night in a circle.
Whereas I struggle to
confess that I didn't
want to explain anything.
Whereas truthfully I wished most
to kick the legs of that man's
chair out from under him.
Whereas to watch him fall
backward, legs flailing,
beer stench across his chest.
Whereas I pictured it happening
in cinematic slow-motion,
delightful.
Whereas the curled
hand I held to my mouth
was a sign of indecision.
Whereas I could have
done it, but I didn't.
Whereas I can admit that also
took place, yes, at least."
I'm going to close
with this last piece.
This is a piece that
I usually close with.
It is a resolution from the
last section, "Resolution 2."
And in the resolutions,
I have used the text
from the actual apology.
I hope I'm OK on time.
How?
OK.
So I have used the text from
the actual "Resolution 2"
in the apology and sort
of reworked it as my own.
"I commend this
land and this land
honor this land Native this land
peoples this land for this land
the this land thousands
this land of this land years
this land that this
land they this land have
this land stewarded
this land and this land
protected this land this land
this land this land this land
this land this this."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- So thank you.
That was really
beautiful and amazing.
We're going to open it
up for some questions.
But first, I just wanted to
offer some brief reflections
on this book but
also the reading.
And you had talked about the
2010 apology resolution, which
was folded into a 1,000
page tome, National Defense
Authorization Act, which I
believe totaled somewhere
around $685 billion for national
defense, which, at the time,
was the largest
defense appropriations
bill, not just in US history
but in world history.
And so I think there is of a lot
of tension that you bring out,
in this idea that
this apology is folded
in with a sort of military
defense appropriations bill,
but, also, that it was
signed into law by President
Obama at the same time
that he reversed the US
decision or the US vote
against the UN Declaration
on the Rights of
Indigenous Peoples.
And he accepted the UNDRIP,
as we call it for short,
on the condition that
it was non-binding.
And so in the language of
the apology resolution,
there's this tension of a
non-binding sort of aspect,
that there will not be
redistribution of land
or the restoration
of things lost.
And so, as you were
reading, I was kind
of thinking about this tension.
And you were you were
talking about apologies.
And it got me thinking
about Crow Dog,
for example Ex parte Crow Dog,
in which Crow Dog murdered
Spotted Tail and then made
restitution, for his family,
for the taking of a relative.
And then the US government
stepped in and said,
we have jurisdiction.
And this apology
is null and void,
and thus we got the Major
Crimes Act in 1887--
I can't remember the exact year.
I'm a historian, but, [LAUGHS]
I know, it's really bad.
But I was just thinking about
all of these things and the way
that your book is really
speaking to these things.
And you had told me, in a
conversation just a little
bit ago, that I'm trained in
the certainty of documents,
whereas you are sort of open
to not knowing and feeling.
And so I just
wanted to maybe ask
you to reflect on
that a little bit
and the readings
that you just gave,
and this notion of apology
and reconciliation,
if there was no
conciliation to begin with.
- Hmm?
[LAUGHTER]
There's like a few
different things
to address there at once.
Right.
Well, maybe I'll talk
a bit about the work.
I'll talk about what I know,
which is the work of the poet.
And even at that, I
know a little bit.
[LAUGHS] There's so much more.
So when it came to,
let's say, this aspect
of this particular document
that I was working with,
which was this national
apology, there are so
many ways to approach it.
But I think that's one of the
things we were talking about
in your office, earlier.
All of us in the community
have different ways of working
and the jobs that we're doing.
So I am not an
essayist, for example.
I'm not a historian.
In fact, I have a piece in here
where I clearly state, bear
in mind, I am not
a historian, right?
I make that crystal
clear, because I
know the tendency of readers
to take any particular story
and make it THE story.
There is a great danger in that.
This is one telling
and one perspective.
And it's from a poet, at that.
So poets are like, hmm?
You know you have to give that--
[LAUGHS] We have our ways of
telling, telling its slant,
right?
But I think like with this--
and so given that,
as an artist, I
think I had to think
of how could I approach
this great document, how
could I approach anything that
was directly political
that in a way
that worked for me as an artist?
Because I'm not a legal expert.
Even sitting here, and you
are giving this little account
of Crow Dog and Spotted Tail.
I was like, wow, this is great.
I could just sit here,
and you could give a talk.
I just loved it.
So there's so much that each--
different kinds of knowledge
that each of us carries, right?
But, of course, there's that--
I've heard that common
saying, if mankind
were a body, a physical body,
poets would be the skin.
We're the ones who feel.
So we feel.
And that's part of what I
think my job is, as a poet,
as an artist.
I am here to feel for you.
So I had maybe a basic
structure to work with,
this legal document.
But it is my job to--
I felt like I wanted to enter
it in a way of thinking about,
how does this make me feel?
How does this
language make me feel?
Even the "Resolutions,"
which are not anecdotal,
necessarily-- like all of the
"Whereas" pieces, most of them
are prose blocks,
and a lot of them
are anecdotes from my own life.
That's one thing.
But even the "Resolutions,"
which are more visual pieces--
you don't have the book, do
you, right in front of you?
A lot of them are visual pieces.
So, for example, I
even have one in here
that is shaped like
a hammer, I think.
Let me see.
Where is it?
Good lord, this is my
book, and I can't find it.
Here it is.
So I have a piece
that's like a hammer.
But even those pieces,
I felt like my intention
was to show what I feel how this
text affects me as a reader.
And so then that's kind
of what I was doing.
I don't even know if I
answered your question.
Did I?
- No, I think the
structure of the book,
with the "whereas"
statements, and, for us,
as historians, when
we read documents--
in the resolution,
there's always
the sort of preamble, which
is the whereas, the whereas,
the whereas, the
whereas, setting up
the reason for the resolution
in the first place.
And so I guess, as somebody who
reads a lot of those documents,
it was something that
really meant a lot.
It was speaking to me.
I felt like it was
speaking to me.
And you and I had
this conversation
about the idea of drawing
from collective memory
and how we interpret
textual documents.
And you had said
something that really
stuck with me in the sense
that you do use Lakhotiyapi,
or the Lakota language,
and that it's surrounded
by English words on the page.
And how these documents,
for us, whether it's
treaties or agreements
that were made,
were made orally, entirely
through the oral tradition,
and were remembered that way.
I don't know if you
want to speak to that.
- Well, I think what you're
saying is very beautiful.
And I want to spend
more time thinking
about it, the orality
of these agreements.
Only because I'm thinking
about when I taught at a tribal
college, Diné College.
I think I was talking,
earlier today,
about teaching a reading class.
That's one of the
main classes I taught.
The very first thing that--
and this was
fundamental reading.
So it was a course to
kind of get students up
to college-level reading.
So we would dive in.
And we read.
I tried to have them read
different kinds of writing.
The very first document we would
jump into was their treaty.
And it was very
difficult language.
In some ways, some of
it is archaic language.
It's not language that we
use, some of the phrasing.
And of course, it's
also legalese, kind
of this governmental language.
It's not easy for them.
But I would say, it's OK.
If it's not easy,
we'll take it slowly.
And we'll do it, together, in
groups, article by article.
You two, you take article one.
That's all I want you to
do is read it together.
And you come back.
And you report to us
what you know about it.
And then bring in examples
from your own family
or your own knowledge,
something that applies
to this particular article.
And that's how we would take it.
And one of the things we would
do, also, at the same time,
is go online.
And we would look up
the actual treaty.
There's online archives,
and you can usually
see the original documents.
And we would go and look
at the very last page
of the signatures
by the leaders.
So we would go online.
And this is Navajo Nation.
This applies to ours, Treaty
of 1868, and what have you.
And we would look at it.
And I would say,
what do you notice
about this, that all
of the leaders' names
are listed and so on?
But what's one of the
first things you notice?
And sometimes it would be quiet.
But anyway, the
point I was making
is all of those signatures
are Xs, all of them.
And that's us, too, up
north, they're all Xs.
So that is the first thing
we would think about.
And what are the
implications of that?
What does that mean?
When our grandfather-- and
I can say that some of us
have grandfathers who
signed those agreements.
What does that mean?
We would have a whole
class on what the X means.
You know, to see that?
But really, then I
would say to them,
OK, listen, we're at
a different time now.
None of us have to be in
that position ever again.
I don't want any of
us to be in that.
So that's why we're
starting, right now,
with your treaty, because
it's the place of power.
Language is a place of power.
Have the language
at your command.
Now, I don't know.
Did I answer your
question again?
- You did.
- Whoo, I went way off there.
Oh, the verbal?
The orality of it?
[LAUGHTER]
That is also what I'm
very interested in.
- Because if you read
the treaty out loud,
it sounds really wonky.
I mean it doesn't
make a lot of sense.
But I mean the way
that it's passed
down, from generation
to generation,
is that it was
translated into Lakota.
Well, for us, it was translated
into Lakota and Diné bizaad
for Navajo.
And then it was
translated into English.
And then it was re-translated
back into Lakota.
And it would go back and forth.
And we had an understanding
of what it meant.
And then whether or not that
was what was finally written
on paper, we had no idea.
Because we couldn't read it.
- Absolutely.
And it makes me think
also of the Maori.
This is what I understand.
If my telling is
wrong, forgive me.
But I used to work at
the Language Institute--
no, the Indigenous Language
Institute for some years.
And we had some people
from the institute
visit the Maori people
to talk about how
they were able to help
their language grow.
In any case, one of the things
I learned from that visit--
I was transcribing notes--
is this renewal of Maori
rights, land rights,
which came back to
their original agreement
with the Crown.
And it all came down to
the translation of one
word, "sovereignty--" one word.
And they were able,
these young Maori lawyers
were able to come
and prove that there
was no direct translation
into Maori language
for that particular word.
And there is no
way their leaders
would have agreed to that.
That is not a
concept, not something
that is practiced in their
culture, complete sovereignty
over a particular
area or what have you.
So beautiful.
And I was saying, I wish
we could do that, you know?
But anyway, that's
another subject.
- I just wanted to
ask one more thing,
because I was thinking a
lot, as you were reading it.
And it's much different to hear
you read the poetry than it
is to read it on the page.
And one thing that I
was reminded about--
and we talked about
this in my office,
but you actually read the piece,
the "Whereas" piece talking
about Lakota meaning
"friend or ally."
And in this case,
you were talking
about a snowstorm and the cold.
And you'll get burned if
you try to push against.
And I was thinking
of this testimony
given by Phyllis Young, who
is a council woman at Standing
Rock, when the Dakota
Access Pipeline was meeting
with the Standing
Rock Sioux tribe.
And she said,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],,
I am Dakota.
Dakota means "friend or ally."
And she was saying this to
the North Dakota officials,
that you are not friends or
allies to the Dakota people.
You are not friends or allies to
the land, and to Dakota Access,
for taking the name of a
nation, to be against the land.
And so I was just like, I'm
going to deep now [LAUGHS]
into what you were writing.
So I really, really
appreciated that.
As we were talking
about, you're dealing
with the tensions in language.
And I think there's another
level of understanding.
And here were talking
about the other
than human element of
the Lakota language.
- Yeah.
Yeah, the relationship and
understanding that, right?
As we were saying earlier, to
be an ally, to be a friend,
extends far beyond
just a people.
It is everything.
We could talk about that
for a long time, yeah.
- Should we open it
up to the audience?
I don't know if there's--
is there a microphone?
I can't-- OK.
She's bringing it around.
And I just want to
remind everyone,
if you have a question,
please make it
a question and not a statement.
And also, try to keep it
relevant to the talk tonight.
[LAUGHTER]
- Thank you so much.
My question is about the piece
you were just talking about,
ally, friend, and
earlier in that piece
you talked about part
in a way that struck me
as being perhaps different
from what I have received
as a European descended
person, which part, as a verb,
means to sunder.
And I think your part was in
many ways bringing together,
sometimes bringing
together things named
and sometimes bringing together
across something that I
didn't understand.
So I'm hoping I can
persuade you to talk
about part a little bit.
- I mean, I think
that, for me, it's just
kind of like a sensibility.
If anything, one of the
things that I appreciate
most about Lakota
sensibility is this idea
of being a part of
things, that all of us,
in any doing or any effort,
we are all coming in.
We're contributing something.
We're a part of that.
And I think the other
part, the other thing
to that is always an
acknowledgment of everyone's
part.
I don't know.
I'm losing my train
of thought here.
I know that when I wrote
that piece, I mean,
I was really just
meditating I guess.
Because I had just
written the other piece
about how we
understand ourselves
as Indian or American Indian,
the dictionary, and so on.
So in that regard, when I
began working on that piece,
I was really
meditating on this idea
of what it is to be Lakota,
yes, friend and ally.
But I think it's also this
idea for me, at least,
always that we are a part of
a greater whole, a community,
a family, [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Like that is always how
we understand ourselves.
It is not an existence that
is I, an alone existence,
a very individual existence.
No, it is an existence that
is always connected to others.
And so, really, that's kind of
what I was getting at, I think.
- Thank you.
- Hi, there.
Thank you for being here.
Appreciated your acknowledgment
that you're not a historian.
But I do think that your
poem "38" has the potential
to really sear that incident
into our consciousness in a way
nothing else has before.
And I'm wondering
if you would just
talk a little bit about
how that poem came to be
and what was involved
in the writing of it.
Thank you.
- So I had heard that story
when I was much younger.
It was kind of like a
verbal account, something
I'd heard a long time ago.
And it always stuck with me.
And what was most
resonant about that story
was the actual moment of
finding Andrew Myrick's body,
and that, when they
found him, his mouth
was stuffed with grass.
That was the moment that
made a huge impression on me
as a young person.
So as I got older, I
mean, there came a point
when I felt like I
really, really wanted to--
I wanted to write about that.
There was something
about it that was just,
I mean, I guess
calling to me, like I
needed to write about that.
But I didn't know how.
I didn't know how
to approach it.
So that actually
took me a long time
to really come to what
the best form would be
and the best telling.
So one of the things
I came to first
was that the way I heard the
story, the telling I heard,
was very straightforward.
It didn't need a lot
of embellishment.
Like just what happened was
enough to make an impact.
So I realized, OK, that was
the first thing in that piece.
I did not need to embellish
it and make it poety and even
create a fictional
character or anything.
I didn't need that.
I didn't need to do that.
So then I realized, OK,
the facts sometimes,
just as they are, are enough.
So that was an important
part of drafting that piece.
I decided to have a very
straightforward, dry tone.
And therefore, I decided
to have the sentence
as the primary
carrier of the poem.
And then, of course, there's
the dual meaning of sentence
within that piece, right?
You have the death
sentence and the sentence,
the grammatical sentence.
So that seemed to work well.
And once I kind of got
myself into the form,
then the wheels started moving.
And I started researching.
I read different
accounts of that moment.
Some of them very--
I say it in the piece.
They're slightly different,
but they all kind of
have the same telling.
I mean they're
slightly different.
There's a lot that I didn't--
I had to be decisive in
what I would include.
There were a lot of interesting
facts around that time
that I did not include.
It's already a six-page poem.
So I had to, at some
point, pick and choose
what was most important to me.
And so part of that
process was readers.
Once I had a draft
that was, I felt,
kind of where I
wanted it to be, I
had several native poets
and a Dakota writer--
people that were, I felt,
knowledgeable and could give me
good feedback--
look at it.
All together, that piece took
about two years to complete.
So it was not a rush job.
I wanted to get it right
if at all possible.
- We have time for
one more question.
- Hi.
Thank you so much.
So when you were answering
Nick's second question,
it made me think about
how much of your book
is kind of about translation.
So there are the poems
near the beginning
of the book, where you're sort
of unpacking Lakota words.
And then the "Whereas"
section is basically
translating the apology
from government into human.
And that made me
think about something
you said earlier, where you
said the poet's job is to feel.
And I guess the two things sort
of smushed together in my head.
And so, basically,
I thought maybe
that's implying that a poet's
job is to translate reality
into feeling.
And that connected to something
from the first or second poem
that you read, where
you were talking
about feeling in your poem
and how feeling is something
with the senses, with the body.
So my question is, when
you're writing a poem,
when you're feeling, do you
have a sense that you use more?
Do you see a poem more
or do you hear it?
- Oh.
Uh-huh.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, that's interesting.
OK.
I'm going to come--
first, I'm going to say
something that is not
quite an answer, but it is.
First, I will say, often, with
students that I'm working with,
I will say, for
me, art or poetry
is a way of thinking out loud.
So you would think that
thinking and feeling
are in contrast to each
other, but they're not.
For me, it's the same.
But it is a way of
thinking out loud.
These poems are my
way of thinking.
So the piece I read, about being
a child and sitting on my side
and thinking, laying like this,
that was an activity for me
as a child.
[LAUGHS] That was
like, I did that.
Like that was so weird.
But it was like
actually a thing.
And it wasn't until I got
older that I said, oh, my god,
there's actually a use for
that, which is something
that I have done all my life.
So I'll sit and ponder
the word "circuitous."
Like what's up with that?
I think it's such a
beautiful word, you know?
And here we go.
I became.
I have a piece where circuitous
had to be in that piece.
I wrote the whole
piece for that word.
[LAUGHS]
Because it needed to be there.
There's a sound.
So now let's get to the senses.
There is a sound, a sound
that is pleasing to me.
And I want to unravel that.
I wrote a whole piece
on the word "opaque."
Because, for years, I thought
opaque might see-through,
the opposite, right?
And I was very upset to
learn it was not see-through.
And I sat and pondered why did
I think opaque means see-through
all these years?
And it was the sound.
It sounds-- oh, pee, ay,
kay-- let's say, a kah.
I dissected that in
the poem to understand
how those sounds translated
to mean see-through to me.
So maybe it's a combination
of all those things
I'm working with.
A lot of sound now that I'm
talking to you about it, yeah.
- Thank you.
- So that concludes
the discussion.
And I just want to thank Layli,
again, for coming out here.
It's such a gift for everyone,
the book as well as the talk.
And so [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
- Oh, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]